this is the first part of a three-part
illusion what do you see well there's a
window and it's turning except it stops
and reverses Direction I'm going to
attach this Rubik's Cube to the short
side of the trapezoid okay the Rubik's
Cube is going around but now what is
that
it looks like the Rubik's Cube is
continuing to go around
but the window is oscillating back and
forth okay new plan I'm going to take
off the Rubik's Cube and I'm going to
put a ruler right through the middle of
the window okay the ruler is rotating
around but wait now the window is going
backwards whoa whoa the ruler is going
through the window it is doing things
which I know are physically impossible
but that is how my brain is seeing